I don't think in my life I've turned
redder this is my worst sexy experience
I've ever had so when I was in high
school I was dating this guy that I
thought I was into but then New Year's
Eve was rolling around and we had
planned this whole party with my friend
he was also dating his friend it was
this whole thing and I realized like
right before New Year's Eve that I
didn't really like him anymore and I was
texting my friend about it and how I was
planning on breaking up with him and how
annoyed with him I was while I was
sitting next to him and I thought I was
sexy my friend but he all of a sudden
got the sex and he like looked at his
phone and he looked at me and I was like
what and he was like what the [ __ ] and I
was like what I don't know like I don't
have your phone and he was like you just
sent me that text and I was like what
text and I started to panic a little bit
and I was like oh my god oh my god
so I looked at my phone and sure enough
I haven't texted my friend the 10-page
thing about how annoyed with him I was I
had texted it to him and we still went
to the party we had fun but we broke up
a couple days later to no one's surprise
so I'm like really bad at saving numbers
in my phone there's a lot of people in
my text messages that just don't have
saved numbers and I just don't always
know who's texting me and so there's one
time that I had this big crush on this
guy and he like had a 3-1 own number or
something like that and all of a sudden
one day he asked me to go to his DJ show
up in North Hollywood and I would like
oh my god oh my god he likes me he wants
me go to the DJ show oh my god oh my god
I should go basically this place is far
this place is so far and I'm driving for
love you know for potential love and so
I get there
and it's like this kind of like weird
bar and I'm like okay I'll find him so
I'm looking around for him and then I
see this guy that I know and basically
he's this creepy guy whose number I got
a long time ago and he kept wanting me
to hang out with him and he's DJing that
night and so I'm just like why is he
DJing
like here what's going on and then I'm
like and so I look at my phone and I
realized that he was the one texting me
creepy dude was texting me not crush
dude it was actually creepy dude and so
now creepy dude thinks that I'm so into
him that I would drive all the way to
his DJ set just to hang out you know
you'd think I learned from that but I
don't so probably about three or four
years after I graduated college I was
working in New York City was having a
steady job
it's feeling great about life and you
know Facebook was the way you
communicated with a lot of people you
know back in college and so I went on a
limb and was talking to this girl hey I
see you're in New York City you know she
just graduated about a year year or so
before I was like we should meet up for
a drink
you know grab some dinner or something
she wrote back say hey would love to I
actually work you know in Midtown which
is where I work I was like great let's
just go grab some dinner after work and
she was like fantastic I didn't want to
like think it was like a date we didn't
called anything was just like hanging
out but I was just like so excited to be
hanging one-on-one we've always vibe we
always had a good conversation in
college but I was always too afraid to
ask her out or I was always dating
someone and she was more she was they
always dating someone so just never the
opportunity arose I told a couple my
friends I was going out with her
some of my friends that went to college
with us as well they were they were
texting me throughout the night and this
is before even iPhones this is just like
regular old school like Nokia phones
like you don't have to press like two
three times to get to B or C and stuff
like that and so I'm texting or she
what's the bathroom I texted and then
my you know to pick some friends like
yeah it's going well we're just have a
good conversation like a month like you
know stressing about it couple drinks go
down and so I just pick up my phone I
start texting my friends like I can't
believe I'm hanging out with this girl
she's so beautiful
you know I just I hope something happens
you know I can't remember the exact this
but I just remember saying she is so
beautiful there phone vibrates and she
goes sorry she goes might be my friend
she opens up the phone and it's a text
from me I texted her I can't believe how
beautiful she is like I'm so happy to be
on this date right now and she looks at
me and she goes huh oh my god why does
everything all right she goes yeah but
did you mean to text me how beautiful I
was I don't think in my life I've turned
redder like a full shade of dark red
like almost like I was choking like I
needed the Heimlich maneuver at the
restaurant and she was just like she's
like it's cute I appreciate it but you
know like I thought this was just like a
friend thing and I was just like totally
is I'm just like you know when you're
just you just you're so embarrassed you
make up every excuse in the book and I
couldn't even come up with an idea of
like oh I was texting about some other
girl cuz I was literally sitting in
front of her and everything in present
conversation so you know we're still
friends we talk every once in a while
but
you
do you know it's Hispanic Heritage Month
no from Loyola people content right here